i had already been involved in the
occult
i had been a freemason i had been a
member of an occult absorb
organization called the anthroposophical
organization founded by rudolf steiner
i had been trained as an initiate
uh i had been trained to leave my body
consciously
and do astral travel i knew all of this
stuff and i knew the occult history
when i read the quran so when i read the
quran
and it talks about the enemies of
mankind in these wicked men
in high places planted by allah in all
of the cities
i knew who they were
it was not an abstract idea for me it
wasn't something that
was just printed words on the paper i
had met them
i had rubbed shoulders with them
[Music]
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively
more than you're influencing them
positively i think you need new friends
podcast in the dunya the three muslims
podcast
we're joined today with a very special
guest
dr omar zaid allah how are you doing
today
i'm wonderful alhamdulillah
thank you for inviting me happy the
pleasure is all ours i just want to say
that subhanallah
so welcome to the podcast um many
viewers are looking at you know
you right now saying masha allah you
know very very uh
good-looking man what is his story
subhanallah you know when i think of the
average muslim
we think of someone like faya it's
subhan allah when we look at you masha
allah
a lot of people are wondering
subhanallah what is his story and you
mentioned before
the army subhanallah and people were
calling you doctor since before you were
a doctor
so do you mind sharing a bit of your
story your journey to islam whether you
were born into it or found it later in
life
oh goodness me that's a long long story
i'll try and encapsulate it briefly
i'm born and raised american in uh as a
catholic
in southern south philadelphia along the
delaware river
a little town called chester that's
where i grew up i graduated
high school 1967. i've been a
professional musicist
musician from the age of 12. i already
had my little band in trio when i was 12
years old my mother was my
booking agent so
i have that experience behind me
and i went off to college at westchester
state college to study music but i
wasn't prepared for college nobody
really prepared me
even though i had a college preparation
course no one explained to me the true
purpose and meaning of education
and that's awfully strange because i've
become an educator
in my late age um anyway i dropped out i
went on the road with a rock and roll
band
and became involved in all the nafs
business of that venue from
new york to baltimore uh in nightclubs
in
all sorts of venues and uh
it was leading me nowhere i like all
musicians i had that
a vision of becoming famous you know and
of course that only happens to one in a
hundred thousand
musicians the rest of us starve or just
uh go to hell so
in any case i uh joined the army
to clean up my act went off to europe
and was in the national guard in active
duty army for the better part of eight
years
i lived in germany for two years i got
out of the army i lived in england for
two years
then i went back to school on a gi bill
and became a doctor and that was a ten
year
experience so i became the
uh well a teacher because that's what
doctor means it means teacher
uh when you look at the greek word greek
root of the word so um
i off i studied allopathic medicine
and i became an emergency room physician
a certified family practitioner
i passed all the examinations and i also
self-trained myself in homeopathy
to balance the medical approach because
by the time i went to medicine medical
school i was a bit older
and not as naive as the younger students
and i saw that there was a great deal of
miseducation taking place and
actually psychologically the educators
were breaking
all the rules of how to properly educate
people and the bias was
very obvious to me they
they teach doctors to treat human beings
like machines
and you know when you go to see an
allopathic doctor you might as well be a
car going to see a mechanic
that's that's pretty much it in a
nutshell
there are sites some people who approach
the dynamics of
the metaphysical aspects of our being
but
most of them don't do not they ignore it
so i uh practiced medicine
for uh a goodly number of years actually
i was practicing
medicine before i went to medical school
because i
was introduced to homeopathic medicine
when i was in germany
years previously so i was beginning to
learn that
i became quite good at it i was a gifted
doctor a gifted homeopathic
physician people came to see me from i
had a private practice as well as a
hospital practice and
people came to see me from halfway
across the country
just simply by word of mouth and um
basically for homeopathic treatment not
the allopathic treatment
and uh for those listening who don't
know about homeopathic medicine i
can we can talk about that another time
but you can consider
homeopathy a form of islamic medicine
that is poorly understood
by most people even in this day and age
and it's being openly persecuted by the
um how shall i say the cattle barons
who are prosecuting the covid uh
sham so um after a number of
uh years as a physician i saw things
going
very badly in the states and
i decided to leave
when i was on the phone with an
insurance
representative trying to get approval
for
the treatment of one of my patients and
they were resisting and resisting
and finally said no and so i it was a
young lady and i said
may i ask you a personal question and
she said of course doctor
and i asked her i said how old are you
and how far did you get on your
education
and she said oh i'm 22 and i graduated
high school i didn't go any further
and so i hung up the phone i thanks
thank you very much and i hung up the
phone and i said well there's the tail
wagging the dog
you see there is an uneducated person
telling
an educated person what they can and
what they cannot do
and that's just the reversal of divine
order
now i wasn't particularly informed well
informed about divine order but
you know that's feature speaking and
so i began to observe things more
closely
and as i was emergency room i closed
down my private practice after that
and i was observing certain aspects of
human behavior in the states and
i worked emergency room medicine and one
day after
getting off duty
i went to my local buffet
breakfast place and there was a family
sitting at the table next to me
they were on holiday and i could hear
them
talking talking and all they
could talk about was whatever they
watched on the movies or on
television they had no other
element in their conversation there was
no element of
the community relationships no element
of
interpersonal relationships everything
was focused on the persons
and the personages that they continued
they considered to be
admirable stars on television or in the
movies
and this fascinated me so i started
listening to
other conversations and pretty much
that was pretty much the state of
conversations
you know it was either that or some sort
of political talk
about you know famous individuals who
were misguiding
the people and there were you know folks
who were
in favor or against and it was a
it was the typical dialectic and all
this dialectic was taking place
according to uh propaganda protocols
which i began to
you know understand in those days and i
had some psychological
uh understanding as a result of my
medical training
so i decided to leave the country
and um uh i
um went to southeast asia
i did what uh imran hussein
uh has suggested i i did the you know
the
the getaway off-grid farming thing in
the mountains of borneo
uh and as a stranger as a white man
that's not really an
easy thing to do i had been divorced and
i married a local
uh tribal lady from the uh biddagu
tribe in east malaysia in the mountains
of borneo
right on the indonesian border there
where up in the mountains they still
have
cannibals to this day and
so i'm up there we cleared some land we
bought some land
and i built a house i spent whatever
savings i had doing this we built a farm
i raised chickens ducks fish
and a few other things in fruit trees
and planted my own rice for the better
part of five years
and in between to support myself as well
i continued to work as a doctor
uh in
[Music]
australia malaysia wouldn't give me a
license they wanted me to go back to
school
and do the whole thing despite having 25
years of
medical experience and
uh this it's a muslim country
and i can tell you right now that most
of the doctors are incompetent
and which is a very sad thing to say so
they refused to
[Music]
give me a license australia gave me a
license and i went to
there to work as a locums i almost
immigrated to
australia but i saw the same things
happening in australia that was
happening in the states
the same mind control dialectical
process was taking place and i said well
no
i don't want to jump from that fire into
this fire so i'll just stay up there and
with the natives and borneo and you know
make the best of it
then uh i was also doing a
sort of christian missionary work
because i became a christian
a few years prior to my relocation and i
was quite serious about it
i still i studied the scriptures i
studied as much as i possibly could and
i was doing preaching
preaching for the local tribes under the
authority of one of their local pastors
whom my wife knew very well she was also
a missionary
and she was a missionary to some of
these cannibal tribes
before i uh before i arrived there these
are the headhunters
and um so um
one day the the chief pastor was unable
to attend christmas ceremony
on christmas morning they invited me to
give the sermon
and i had been studying intently
the pagan origins of the christian
system
and so i gave the sermon that day on
christmas morning about the christmas
about the pagan origins of the
celebration and on
the name of jesus christ because it's
not uh it's not
christian at all it's not islamic at all
nobody
he ever knew called him jesus including
his mother you see
so i i did this and i gave the sermon
and this was a pentecostal church you
know in the pentecostal church you get a
lot of amens and
hallelujahs and thank you jesus and all
this sort of thing
i've been there done that and
they there was no amens
there were no thank you jesus no
hallelujahs when i finished my sermon
what you would call the khutbah there
was pure
absolute silence
now the head pastor's
daughter who got up she was also an
assistant patch pastor and
usually took over when he was gone and
she took the podium after i sat down
and she said address the audience and
she said there were about three or four
hundred people there
and she said oh well
i know you're all shocked by what the
doctor has said
but everything he said is true
so let us pray and so there was a somber
prayer and the service was closed and
we left and uh there was some murmuring
but no thank you jesus and no
hallelujahs
there was no joy left in that
pentecostal church i had wiped it out
with the truth and three days later
uh the chief pastor came to my farm i
was sitting on the
porch in a rocking chair just
contemplating whatever i was doing
and he came up approached me and said
you know i understand what you did the
other day
and i have to dismiss you from your post
as a teacher
in our congregation and i said i can
explain he said no explanations
necessary
you're you're welcome to come and uh you
know join us for services and pray but
you can no longer teach so
i thanked him very much and he went on
his way
and i never went to that church again it
was my
custom to pray twice a day at sunrise
and sunset
and so for the next year that's what i
did while i was attending to the farm
and a year later my uh wife was pregnant
with our second son and she gave birth
and went to live with her mother
for the postpartum period
i never let any of my wives get up out
of bed for
at least six to eight weeks after they
gave birth and all of them
too many probably all of them were back
in their genes
within two or three weeks thank god
but i knew what medicines homeopathic
medicines and how they should be treated
in order to do that and i can explain
that in another session if need be
anyway she was with her uh mother and i
was alone at the farm
and i brought a large library with me
from the states it was an extensive
library
and i had read most of the books two or
three times and there's i was looking
for something to read again
in her absence and uh there was one book
there i hadn't read it was a copy of
yusuf ali's translation
of the quran so i picked it up and i
said okay satan i'm gonna find you
and i said i'm i was determined to find
how it was that uh satan had
uh misled misguided millions and
billions of people these last 1400 years
or so
and so i opened up the book and i opened
it up to the first prayer
and then
[Music]
i was shocked i said my god
that's the most perfect prayer i've ever
read let's see
and i said boy iblis is really smart
so i continued reading and it
i couldn't put the book down i read
night and day for three days
then i finally closed the book and i
went immediately
to the bible to the uh
almost the last page in the bible to
revelations book of revelations chapter
22
and there saint john the revelator is
having a conversation with a messenger
that some people
consider to be an angel
others consider to be jesus many
i think the theologians in the christian
congregations are
maybe half you know split half and half
it was an angel or it was jesus
in any case angel means messenger and a
messenger can be a prophet we all know
that
most christians don't know that but you
know that's they don't take their
faith seriously not just to really study
it
like most muslims you see and that's a
big problem
because uh gibril said
to the prophet the first word was read
was it not of course it was you can't
become
educated if all you do is recite
recitation is insufficient you have to
read
and i can expound on that later any case
in this conversation that john is having
with jesus after all these wondrous
visions that he had he then is so
astounded and so moved he kneels down
and to worship uh this messenger
and the response from the messenger it's
right there
in this in this in this books right
there in the new testament is
the messenger says do it not
i am a man like you from the tribe
of judah worship god alone
there it was right there now i had read
that many times but
it never i never understood it
until after reading the quran so i
closed the book
and there it was after midnight and in
the privacy of my little living room in
that farmhouse up in the mountains in
borneo i confessed a shahada to the
angels to the jinn and whatever animals
were listening
you see and la ilaha
muhammad and rasulallah
and i became a muslim nobody preached to
me
now the background to that is the fact
that
i had studied the scriptures and i
studied the parascriptural
literature extensively in between
all of my work as a doctor and
whatever else i was always reading
that's why they called me doc
as a when i was in in the army they
called me doc because
i was the only one with an open book
almost everywhere you went
everywhere every time you saw me i was
reading
i knew 40 50 years ago that the vaccines
were a scam
and medically unsound i was the first
one in the
army to refuse the swine flu vaccine
they arrested me for it so as a
background
of extensive reading uh
with a background of sex extensive
reading when i read
the quran and then i came to this
passage there
i mean there were a couple of passages i
came across and i just wept
but um i came across one passage
that essentially said we have given the
koran as a
mercy and as a blessing and to complete
what came before well i'm
here to tell you that i read that book
knowing
what came before and not only knowing
the scriptures or the paris scripture or
literature but also the history
i had already been involved in the
occult i
had been a freemason i had been a member
of an occult
organization called the anthroposophical
organization founded by rudolf steiner
i had been trained as an initiate
uh i had been trained to leave my body
consciously
and do astral travel i knew all of this
stuff
and i knew the occult history when i
read the quran so when i read the quran
and it talks about the enemies of
mankind in these wicked men in high
places planted by allah
in all of the cities i knew who they
were
it was not an abstract idea for me it
wasn't something that
was just printed words on the paper i
had met them
i had rubbed shoulders with them over
the years
okay and i knew
the way in which they manipulated people
which is one of the reasons i left the
state since
war i'd never go back so
in the privacy of my living room i
became a muslim
now within a
day or two my wife came to
get some clothes because she was feeling
better and she wanted to get back into
some of her
regular clothing so she came to pick
them up and before going back to her
mother's because
at the time the period wasn't up and i
said i have something to tell you
i've become a muslim and of course she's
absolutely shocked no and she was
speechless
she i mean she really couldn't respond
to me
and she gathered her clothes and she
said
i have to go and out the door she went
next day she came back there
and had an uncle and brothers okay
and they told me uh the one brother who
had
the best english he
spoke for all of them and he said i
understand you've become a muslim
and i said yes i can explain what's
happened he said we don't want an
explanation we want you gone
it's just like that now i had invested
all of my life savings in whatever cash
and
whatever what not in this place
and i was a stranger in the strange land
i left my job in
australia because i had was becoming too
old
to travel back and forth like that and
live out of a suitcase it was making me
sick
and my wife had become sick and i didn't
want to entrust her
to the surgeons in the
melee medical system
because most of them are incompetent not
all but most of them are
and they think otherwise but this is a
problem with the human denial so
and the medical education system which
they've copied from the west
see they've made partners with the jews
and the christians and they're jumping
right into the lizards whole
as this exactly like this the the
the the prophet
said so uh i stopped working
and i just got i just continued my farm
work
i was the only white man in that that
they'd ever seen
uh planting rice on on them in
petty rice on the mountains and raising
fish and ducks and chickens
and i would take them to the i'd
slaughter them and take them to the wet
market myself
you see and that market is uh about 20
miles 20 20 25 kilometers from my farm
and it was run predominantly by the
chinese merchants
and i had a little stall there and i
sold my fish and
whatnot and there was it we made enough
money just to get by
but after my conversion um
[Music]
i had to leave and that was taking some
while i asked them to
to give me 30 days
you know 30 days to make preparations
near greed and then to make a long story
short we
we tried to patch up the relationship it
didn't work i had to
i eventually did leave after the 30 days
were up
about almost a year later during that
year i wrote my first book
trinity the um
the metaphor metamorphosis of myth
and um i really uh elaborated on
all of the knowledge that led to the
sermon that i had given the year
previously and um uh
it was my first major uh book
and uh i remember my my wife standing
over me at one point
asking me what i was doing and she
looked at the computer was
look at some of these things i was
writing she said are you sure you want
to write about that
i said yeah yeah i have to i have no
choice
and i said as god is my witness this
book will be published
and about a year later uh
some uh a publisher from west malaysia
contacted me and invited me uh to
come to kuala lumpur and he provided me
with a small income
and a shelter for about three or four
months and
that that invitation occurred just at
the moment when
the melee government in uh
west in east malaysia changed the
immigration laws and i was no longer
able to stay because they required
foreigners
uh you couldn't get residency just
because you were married
you had to be retired with the
substantial pension
and i had no pension and uh
they wanted you to leave across the
border every month
which i had been doing but i used to
cross the border and just come back the
same day
so it was just a trip across the border
in the border wasn't far from me
but now they wanted you to stay for two
or three days and that required to host
hotel expenses and i didn't have the
money for that
so i had to leave
and this man invited me like they're
coming for you
they're coming for you in the background
yes
yeah they're coming for me right my son
will like him brother
um i had to
i had to leave and uh he invited me so
anna provided me a way to go
he bought my airplane ticket he gave me
a place to stay
and gave me a small income
in order to help me to get my feet back
on the ground there in west malaysia
rather than east malaysia and i i did
some things there
i was editing to reinvent myself and i
was writing
so i did some editing work and that
helped me to get by
put rice in my bowl but i was always
living on the edge
you see always living on the edge of
poverty and i was on more than one
occasion i was
just a step or two away from being
thrown out on the street
not because i was undesirable but
because i couldn't pay the rent
and each time i came back close allah
provided another
uh uh made another provision another
connection another uh housing another
kind of job
and in any case um uh the book
uh was written and it was reviewed it
got reviewed by one of the
most pious men i've ever met
and he was also the vice president of
the islamic university there and
he reviewed the book and wrote an
introduction to the book
the book hadn't been practiced it hadn't
been published but he
he wanted he asked me if he could have
the manuscript because somebody
told him about the book and he's and he
wanted to meet me
he actually came to my farm uh and he
made a special
trip from west malaysia east malaysia to
meet me on my farm and we missed each
other
and i was in one place he was in another
place and he had to go back so
in any case um uh
he told me about a year after i had
relocated to west malaysia
that i would have to leave because the
secret police were going around behind
me to everyone who was trying to employ
me or
help me telling them that i was a cia
agent
and i said gosh i wish i was i'd have
some money in my pocket
you know he said you're going to have to
lead the country
and i said okay but i don't know where
to go and i had to
leave the country every month anyway so
i used to go
across the border because it was the
closest border uh to thailand
and just come back the same day and i
usually did that by train
and um uh
[Music]
on one of those uh journeys i met
a buddhist monk who was from
sri lanka and this was a
a monk from a a
sect of buddhism that did not practice
idolatry you see
buddha was a monotheist which is
something that most people don't
understand
he hated statues and idolatry and
burning incense and all this nonsense
this is not his religion at all not in
the original pristine form
and this monk was the first monk that i
met who
admitted that and he said he was on his
way to thailand to
to do some preaching to that effect and
so we got to talking and talking and
he's and i told him my story and he said
oh i know somebody who needs an
english teacher and i said you do
and he said yes here you can call her
and so he called this i
he called this lady on his phone and i
talked to her
and she hired me over the phone to be an
english teacher in bangkok
right because this was a private uh
school
that uh that catered to professionals
you know lawyers and doctors and
graduate students who wanted to go to
the west and
perfect their english so uh i got the
job
and professor other finn zojaime who
wrote the introduction to my book and
told me i had to lead the country i
told him i said well i have a job i just
don't have money to get there
and he reached into his park and he said
i know
he he took out some money
these were american dollars which he had
held on to for about 30 years
in his bedroom top bedroom door didn't
know what he was going to do with them
until that moment he handed them to me
and that was enough to get me to bangkok
pay for my
first month's rent and food you see
and so there it is you know allah
provided for me again so i went to
bangkok
and i taught english for a year and in
the meantime
my manuscript made its way to the desk
of professor osman bakar
who was then the research director at
istak which is a graduate school the top
graduate school for muslim
alim in malaysia and
a part of the international islamic
university system of malaysia
so he read the manuscript and then he
called me
because here at the end of that first
year in bangkok i was about
to be expelled from the country again
because they changed the rules
about to being qualified for english
teacher
so here i was the medical doctor
with you know all those years of
experience
and i was about to be thrown out of the
country because i didn't have an english
qualification you see
most of the english teachers who teach
english
don't have half the qualifications i had
but they have a piece of paper saying
they
do this is the nonsensical
climate of the society that we're now
living in
so um he called me i got this phone call
i'm a month away from leaving the
country from leaving bangkok
and he called me and he said dr omar i'm
professor osman bakar
and i'm at the iium istaq
campus and i want to know i've read your
book
and i'm really impressed with it i want
to know if you'd come back to malaysia
if i got your position at the university
and i said sir if you did
i'd consider that an act of god and i
would have no choice
and so he called me back the next day
it's on and so
he sent me money and i became
an alim overnight
i was hired by the university without
going to any
interview process without any
application
purely on his word from having read my
book
okay and that's
nothing short of the miracle so
uh or equivalent to it
i mean it's not waters coming out of
your fingers but that's uh
it was seemed like it to me at the time
okay so
um i went back and you know i was really
shocked because when i signed the
contract
that i hadn't interviewed for it was
just put in my hands
uh it says as an alien you are required
and i read all these requirements i
but i said me i can barely pray in
arabic you're calling me and not lim now
i'm an alim
how does this happen you see
and osman bakar is a fine man
one of the finest men i've ever met god
bless him
and he was head of the georgetown
islamic georgetown university islamic
center
for several years before returning to
malaysia
he was the chairman of that department
at georgetown university
and that's not a light position so
when he brought me back to kuala lumpur
they put me in a very fine two-bedroom
apartment in a an exclusive sort of
condominium
i was given a job i was given a salary
that was twice
the amount they usually give to
entry-level research fellows
i was a research fellow as an alim
and i
approached him on the first day on the
job and he immediately wanted me to
write two books he said i want you to
find the book of abraham
which is a book nobody's found and um
andy i want you to write uh a book on
the gospel of barnabas
so the book of abraham i'm still working
on it's going to i'm putting it into a
novel form
and i hope to be able to finish that
before i leave this place
[Music]
the book of barnabas was entitled the
forgotten saints and so i wrote that
book
and in the research in the process of
writing that book
i discovered that this one gospel
is the link between isa and mohammed
there's absolutely no doubt in my mind
now i know that there's some uh
controversy about its uh providence
but it's legitimate and uh whatever the
controversies are
they're based on uh italian
spanish um conflicts within the roman
catholic church one family vying against
another family
for papal power and they used the gospel
and then they made interpolations and
all that sort of thing but the original
gospel
like the original injeel is perfectly
understandable
if you erase all of these interpolations
and that's not an easy thing to do
because
um you have to be well read
to do it and most people including
muslim malim are not
so i was able to do that and then
god be praised i recommend that people
should read that book
because it it clearly makes the
link between issa and
prophet muhammad and so i
continued working uh in malaysia
as an alien in this university and
a few other universities for the next 10
years
and then at the age of um how old am i
now 72
about four or five years ago i had a
collapse in my health
i suffered multiple sclerosis
it i just collapsed one day when i came
home
and i couldn't work anymore and thank
god
now uh you know if you saw me four years
ago i couldn't walk without assistance
now i can because i've modified my diet
and a few other things and
i'm able to manage but i'm still
crippled and then i had a major heart
attack so i retired
no i retired to thailand
i had a thai wife after divorcing the
christian wife
and a few other wives in between it
didn't work out
including a born muslim i really wanted
a muslim wife i couldn't find a decent
one who was willing to marry me
they all wanted you know a house and a
car
and you know all these other things they
you know had nothing to do with islam
um and yeah we we can talk about
marriage on another occasion
i've heard some of your comments on it
it needs to be addressed
and um so i i did that thing in the born
muslim woman she was from indonesia
and she turned out her what i thought i
married her for piety not because i was
attracted to her
but i was attracted to her piety and i
needed a muslim wife you see and
so she married me and she knew i wasn't
attracted to her
and she became the well
one of the worst wives i've ever had i
married the taiwa who converted
to islam and i really loved her uh
in all the realms and um the
born muslim wild wife became so jealous
that i had to divorce her it was just
impossible to live and we lived together
in the same house
and why do you do that well that's what
the prophet did isn't it
of course it is he lived his way all his
wives except
the um the christian wife they all lived
with him at the masjid
you know they all had their little rooms
right next to each other in the masjid
they would wake up in the morning say
assalamu alaikum sister how shall we
serve our lord
and our husband today well at least
that's what they should have said
muslims today you know
the muslim is today they don't have this
attitude you know they want the car
they want the fancy dress they want the
gold they want the you know
whatever it is they want to be treated
equal okay
uh they don't understand what equality
means because
no one's thinking clearly
so anyway i did i
i retired to thailand after my collapse
in
health i had a heart attack about a year
later
and a major surgery requiring
quadruple bypass surgery and
of that group of people who experienced
surgery in thailand that months at that
hospital
i'm the only one still alive they've all
died
so i'm living on um
extra grace now i would imagine because
you know as a as a professional musician
i picked up some bad habits and one of
them was smoking i smoked for
45 years and so it's been now four years
that i've stopped
and it's been a great improvement i
still have some way to go
so my thai wife after my retirement and
my disability
she reverted to some of her pagan ways
having taken charge and uh
usurping the dominion in the marriage as
the
the the one who drives and handles
everything
and uh i was helpless and it
the things got worse and worse and worse
and then recently
uh allah provided me a way out
and it was a way that i didn't like
because i swore and everyone who knows
me personally
knows that i swore i would never return
to america
and now i'm here in kentucky with the
new wife
who's perfectly suitable for me and
she's also a revert from china
and it looks like we're pretty well
matched
now the reason we got hooked up so to
speak if i can use that lingo
is that allah gave me a dream about uh
10 months ago or so and then at the same
time or relatively
a month later or so allah gave her the
same dream
in my version of the dream i didn't know
i was with a woman but i she was behind
me okay
in her version of the dream i was in
front of her she knew exactly who i was
but it was the same dream and
so we kind of decided well that's pretty
meaningful
and then we waited for a few other signs
after his dakara and all that sort of
thing
and allah made it uh possible for me to
literally escape thailand and join this
woman
uh and we were married a couple of weeks
ago by
um at uh at under the auspice of
omar baylosh in buffalo new york
baylosh and i had been meanwhile doing
some
interviewing like we do here for the
last year or so
so now i'm in kentucky and uh
it's it's wonderful to be here
i think kentucky is one of america's
best kept
secrets and i shouldn't say that because
i really should keep it that way
but anyway
that's my story so far today there's a
lot more but
i think i've encapsulated 72 years
in about 20 minutes or so i i don't know
how long it's taken down oh inshallah
okay yeah marshall hold on before anyone
says anything
what are you doing now for work if i if
i could ask that
oh i'm retired i'm on tension so you you
don't do anything at
all but not for active work no i
i i write and i uh counsel people
on occasion people pay me for you know
feedback counseling and
i get some income from the sales of some
of my books not very much but i'm on
social security pension because
i worked all these years they took all
those taxes from me all these years and
i
i get a pension and uh we have some
uh my wife amina has some means
and so she's one of these women who said
come to me she said give me your name
uh after this dream and you don't have
to house me you don't have to clothe me
i'll take care of that
so this is an answer uh a living proof
of what the prophet said is going to
happen in these
times and she's a reasonable woman
and she understands that good men are
for good women
you see and good women are for good men
now
most people don't understand the depth
of that
statement you see you know you study the
numbers and you look at the situation on
the streets
and you see that there are very very few
good men there's just not enough to go
around
so the sister who is reasonable
and who wishes to obey our
lord our king of the universe and
the prophet's example of sunnah
should desire for her sister what she
has for herself you see and uh the
problem is
uh not that the men are incapable
most of the men who are trying to
practice polygamy are in fact incapable
they can't even manage one life let
alone more but the women are the real
problem
because they're too selfish there's
nothing worse
then i mean it's bad enough when you got
a selfish man but
selfish women are the worst creatures on
the face of the earth
you see and that's known historically
nobody wants selfies woman for boss yeah
i mean
i mean they're cruel
i know but the reason i asked is because
your voice is so crispy it sounded
voila it sounded like i was listening to
a story just being narrated
like you ever watch a movie and you have
the uh the narrative background
yeah well i would say it was more like
an actual movie
and someone was narrating so i literally
felt like you have them
you felt that too all three of you
yeah listen listen if you if there's by
some chance
that you can get a hold of some kind of
equipment
i do believe that you could use your
voice
just to narrate books like it wouldn't
take any effort
it wouldn't take any effort from you
except just
speaking and reading the book you could
read your own books you could read other
people's books
but listen you have the voice gift
yeah you have the gifts yeah i
i i guess i'm in the zone as they speak
so thank you very much brother but uh i
i'm just telling the story
you're absolutely correct that's what i
i've told
the story in in a way that should be
uh uh and uh
acceptable narrative it's the kind of
thing that you know used to happen
you see this used to happen all the time
before the age of radio
and all this sort of thing in the
evenings what do people have to do
in the 19th 18th century century they
they
each suffer then there's uh an hour or
two
of some sort of domestic entertainment
and uncle so and so comes to visit so he
tells the story
or auntie so and so comes a visit and
they tell the story
and that's how people became
informed they would have a
can i say that word they would have a
conversation
you see an exchange of heart to heart
okay i mean really heart to heart so
that's what's taking place here i'm
giving the narrative
and i'm giving it in a heartfelt way
and it's coming natural because this
is what allah has freed me from
uh these selfish preoccupations that
come with the nuts you see and when
you're freed from that
then you can serve the truth
and you serve the truth wherever you
find it
and wherever you find the truth you find
islam
so the truth doesn't always look like a
muslim
that's the truth of the matter and so
when you hear the narrative like that's
going hard to heart you're having
exchange
because you you see if you're actively
listening to me
then that's your heart is responding you
see
to what i'm sharing and
this is an activation this is an
activity okay
and it's bilateral okay when you have
people who are preoccupied
with their own nerves and their own
ideas their own
their own ideations their own biases
they don't listen or they don't tell the
story
they can't tell the story because they
don't have the narrative
they don't have a real narrative that
holds on to the truth
you know so uh i
i i thank you for sharing that with me
uh brother is it angel hunger
so thank you uh that's that's
encouraging
uh i like to i like to
teach but i only really only like to
teach people who want to listen
who want to learn and who have the
capacity
to listen and to hear you see
and to see metaphysically what is taking
place
now if you see metaphysically what was
taking place in my life as i related
that narrative
that's a sign of guidance you see
and this is something that enriches
not only me but enriches you as well so
teachers need students who can help them
enrich themselves because each time we
people like me give the narrative
we're learning something new because
there's there's things in us that we
don't necessarily know
that we know and when they teach and
when a student asks a question i often
find myself speaking in terms
that i hadn't really considered
consciously before
but they were already there so it's like
the student who's sincere
and who listens um will
draw out from me like a
bucket from the well and they'll draw
out waters that
i don't even know that are there so this
is an
exchange that is blessed uh by
angelic presence you see and
that is a form of guidance that is
missing
in the ummah today it's missing you go
to juma on friday you fall asleep during
the kutba
this is not happening you see this
exchange is not there
why bill because the muslims are the
imams are giving the same old nonsense
the same old religious you know they're
spinning the wheel
they're they're they're on a plane
they're not on a spiral that ascends to
heaven
it just doesn't happen and that's why
you know sure everyone wants to go and
be blessed and have their sins forgiven
but
my god i i've been to jummah so many
times and i see just
people just falling asleep the brothers
are always sleeping they're not enough
that's because the imams are not uh
inspired
they're not speaking from the heart this
heart to heart exchange is not taking
place
and it's been a rare experience
in my 15 years as a muslim
to actually experience that doing jummah
and the the imams who can do that
they're usually dismissed by government
officials
because if you can do that then you
get too close to the truth that makes
the government officials
uncomfortable you see yes
let me let me just add in uh and first
of all man masha allah just hearing your
story
wonderful like i have so many things to
that i want to get across
so first thing this will not be
the only episode that we film with you
there is no way that we can get
and i'm sure i don't need to ask the
three brothers right now they're on the
same page
there's no way we can get everything
that we want to discuss with you in one
episode from the
minutes that we've been talking uh so if
you guys made it back you know made it
this far
write down hashtag dr omar or you know
what write hashtag
bring back dr omar that's gonna be
first thing number two rami i want you
to try to list if you can like on a note
or something
all the points that i'm going to bring
up just in case i forget
if that's not too much so bismillah the
first thing
i wanted to discuss was
you mentioned you kind of left and just
you know left the grid
started you know living taking sheikh
imran hussein's advice
so you know raising your own stuff not
relying on the system so that's the
first thing
so romney if you can write that down the
second thing i
wanted you to go in on coveted right
this is something that
is going on today you mentioned a little
bit about that maybe a little bit into
the vaccines too
and once that's done the third thing we
can talk a little bit about the occult
so i know we can't talk about everything
today
no no so i guess at least let's cover
the first part inshallah
so the first one was why you decided to
leave
the grid and kind of just you know be
off the radar
well you see i was very
cognizant of the fact that i was
surrounded by
um colleagues neighbors
family and acquaintances
that were all under a form of mind
control they were no longer thinking
clearly
and this puzzled me
and i studied the matter a little bit
and came to realize that it was a result
of propaganda
and propaganda didn't extend only to
the television and to movies and this
sort of thing
it extended to the educational system
that the entire educational system had
become
a vessel of propaganda for occult
powers okay and they had determined
that they were going to keep people
ignorant of
certain matters that uh were just not to
be raised
okay and certain historical events
certainly
historical matters certain theological
discussions were just not to be had
in the educational system now i was
brought up a catholic and
i was probably a member of one of the
last generations that had a reasonably
decent education
before this thing called
uh what's it called the the latest
approach to education
came out which is destroying the public
mind in any case
um when i went to uh school
as a young man we were still able to
study
uh history and literature and a foreign
language
and you know we had to become proficient
in mathematics and
that sort of thing in music so all of
these were kind of
balanced in the educational system
they're not anymore
okay so um i was fortunate in the
realm and even though i didn't
my first round about uh with the college
university system was was
a failure when i returned i was much
better informed
and i knew why i was going to become a
doctor and i was
more well-read as well and
so i saw all of this happening both
from especially what happened to me as
an american was i lived overseas
uh for four years the better part of you
know more than four years before coming
back to the states
and going to school as a medical student
so i was able to see
how mind controlled the population was
because i
had had this broader experience living
as an expat overseas
i'll give you an example one of my first
days at the student union
in the university of south dakota
i i was walking down the hallway and
there was announcement on the radio that
anwar sadat had just been assassinated
so i quickly ran
into the uh student union uh
television room and there i'd never been
in television
room you see and there to my surprise
i saw all these couples boys and girls
boys and girls young young men and women
sitting next to each other and they were
all watching soap operas
i walked up to the television and i
changed the channel in front of all of
them
and i said something important just
happened and i changed the news station
and there they were tell telling what
happened with
morris morrison now he was assassinating
everything and i was shocked
and i'm listening to this and they are
all booing me and hissing me out of the
room
and i turned around and i said don't you
know who this man is
they said we don't care and no they
didn't know who he was and by i mean
you know egypt you know who cares about
egypt you see
who cares about such things turn
the channel back to the soap opera
that was the demand and so i looked at
this i stayed in the room a few minutes
and i saw these young men
all trying to please their women
so they can get in their pants
by watching the soap opera that's what
the reality was
manhood was on the decline it was
we were so i was surrounded by a society
of what one famous uh european uh
professor called boy
men okay he said the the post-war
generation has raised the generator is
raising
boy men these are men who never achieve
manhood
all right and they are governed by their
women
okay this is not the way to serve allah
and of course i didn't know that at the
time but
uh having experienced that and then
going to medical school and seeing
the propaganda and the bias and the
unscientific approaches to
education and even the art of medicine
because medicine is an art
it's not just a science
i
i just decided to leave okay
and i said you know this can't be good
the society is headed
downhill and it's going to be a steady
decline from here
on out and there's nothing that can save
such a society and i had determined that
simply
on the basis of fijra and what little i
knew of history and then later on i
found out that you know this is in fact
the case it was a sign of a corrupt
society and uh as i studied the history
of our cattle barons
you know this only confirmed their hand
in matter that's why i wrote the book
the hand of hebless
because that's what it is it's the hand
it's the occult hand
of the highest orders of occult
science that in the service of iblis
and uh you know at the helm there you
have
certain free masonic organizations but
there are other occult
organizations that are far superior to
that
and they date way way way back uh
to and precede that
and i i've written about that history in
another book called
keynes creed the cult of rome
and i have some series of lectures which
i hope to
post on the internet to explain this
clearly
uh for students like yourself young men
like yourself
in any case i couldn't stand to be with
uh people uh who were honoring
boy men you see as their leaders
and liars as their leaders i just
couldn't put up with them anymore
and i decided to leave and go off grid
as much as i can
and that's what i did now
the difference between now and then you
see i'm
doing it again but this is 20 years
later
i'm doing it again because the first
time i did it i did it of my own
volition
see i did not do it with other's
guidance
i was following my own reason my own
thinking making my own associations
making my own plans doing things
my way like frank sinatra you see
and uh it all failed
now allah and his mercy rescued me from
that
uh mud of uh chaotic
thinking that's brought about by
arrogance and pride
even though i'm right about my
assessments i was still arrogant about
it you see
and you can't uh accommodate the truth
and you can't
honor allah with any degree of arrogance
left in your soul it's got to be wiped
out
you see and then i come to find out
later you know this is the sufi goal
you see and i said well okay all right
i'm
i'm getting there you see and i'm not
doing any of these sufi practices
almost just sort of beating it out of me
um so um that's why i left
you see so i said okay i'm going to go
to some place where
people are still holding the families
together that's my idea
and i'm going to go get a good christian
wife
from one of these societies again my
idea
and i'm going to take all my money and
i'm going to build a farm
in some place and i said that's my idea
again my idea you see
and i did all these things i put in a
water system i put in solar power and
all this sort of thing
and what did anna do you ripped me right
out of it
you see ripped me out of it
because it was my idea it wasn't his
idea
let's see and uh i learned that lesson
the hard way and uh now people are
always writing writing to me what a what
about israel
how how can you do these things what can
you do and then
of course i learned some things
practical things from this experience
that i can now use now as i
as i kind of redo the uh the whole
nine yards of going off grid
and becoming as sustainable as possible
when confronting the years to come
because the years that are in front of
us
are years of precipitous decline
there's no doubt about that and so your
listeners are well advised
to do istikara and to seek allah's will
and as to how to manage this and i get a
lot of requests about it a lot of
requests about this
and you know some of us are going to be
able to do it and others are not
i mean the prophet made that very clear
he said when you see all these things
you know run to the hills uh take your
camel your sheep or whatever and go like
the bedouin
he didn't say go live like the muslim he
said go live like the bedouin
most of the most of the bedouins in his
day were not muslim
okay uh and um
they but these are people who are
indigenous people who understand the
land
okay they can read the land like you
read a book
okay and he said go live with them
because they will help you to survive
so they're going to provide your ark
okay
so some people can do that but you can't
just decide you're going to go do it
you have to do it with guidance allah
has to provide the connections
the relationship you've got to have a
relationship
in order to enter into these
circumstances so
what else did the prophet say about it
he said well when you see these things
if you can't run to the
mountains issa said the same thing by
the way
um he said then you you know
you go get a piece of bark and you go
sit by a tree and chew on it until you
did
it's going to be better to do that you
see so
you know can you build an ark can you do
israel in the city you probably can
to a certain extent it's going to be
limited you get yourself a small
high-rise you know
maybe eight nine ten uh floors if you
can afford
it and you you know you do the babylon
thing you get some hanging gardens do
aquaponics and that sort of thing
and you might then do roof gardening and
patio gardening on the balcony and
probably uh be sustainable
to a certain extent but still the hordes
the hungry hordes and they're coming
they're going to come
at you and you're either going to have
to shoot to kill
or you're going to have to go find a
place to chew on that piece of bark
yo i'm shocked bro oh man the reason i
know
yo just i'll let you just tell tell them
uh you know what we were talking about
last few weeks
yeah so that's i mean that's the
situation that we're facing
so um i've i've done it uh
on two occasions now this is my second
approach at it in my declining years and
i hope i have enough time left to get to
get my
young wife settled in and as sustainable
as possible
for the years to come and in the
meantime i'll finish that book of
abraham
in my novel because that's i'm putting
it
in a narrative form in the novel form
and that's
the goals that i've asked allah i said
please don't kill me until i'm finished
that novel you know
this was been one of my prayers and so
um
uh i hope after we settle down we've
just moved in
uh a couple weeks ago and we're settling
in and we're making the plans for the
sustainable development
of uh we've got about five acres here
and we've got a
fully stocked pond with all kinds of
fish in it and we want to
turn the land into
i'm going to talk about something here
that
has just come to me recently as a
revelation because
people have asked me well what do you
think about what's going on in jerusalem
and all that sort of thing and you know
my response is look
the rock of abraham has been there for
millions of years and it can take care
of itself it doesn't need you to protect
it
and that masjid that's built there
uh that wasn't there when the prophet
made his mirage
okay and that temple mount is not the
site of the
uh the prophet of the temple of suleiman
it's just not the right place that's an
old roman fortress
that's what it is so people are
you know pretending to be pretentiously
pious
you know in defense of this thing and
outraged because of what the jews are
doing
and i'm saying look yeah that's a form
of idolatry
now why do i say that oh my gosh dr omar
you're so blasphemous
well look muslims have lost their
autonomy
they lost it centuries ago
not just recently centuries ago this
whole thing about taking over palestine
it's been
centuries in the planning okay
centuries in the planning and little by
little
the muslim leaders have just let it
happen
because they're poorly informed and when
you're poorly informed about science
about history about your own religion
about what came before
you'll see you can't make the right
decisions
you can't lead the people and maintain
allah's protection and refuge and that's
what's taking so the
the women go out into the streets after
you know another bombing
and they say where is the god of
muhammad
he's not protecting you why
why isn't he protecting you that's a
question that you need to ask
why are the jews walking into that
temple mount
and shooting anybody they want that's a
question you've got to ask
because allah said if you do this
we go back to the abrahamic comment
covenant if you do this
this this is an instant you will
maintain your dominion
and i will throw when you throw
yeah almost not throwing the angel just
sitting there and say well
you know can we throw with them no no
they don't deserve my refuge they don't
deserve my protection
look what they're doing to their women
look what their women are doing
look how they're robbing from each other
look how they're stealing from each
other
look how they're backstabbing each other
look how they're lying
look at their stupid alim telling
everybody to take this
bloody immunization that's from hell
all right so i i'm just not going to
honor that
i'm not honest the truth he honors the
truth
when we say get up and say nightfair we
say
thou art the truth do we not
and that's why i said about 10 15
minutes ago
you live in the truth i'm in the truth
zone
i am in the truth zone and i happen to
know it you see
and i'm not saying that arrogantly i'm
saying that
in a pious manner because it's happened
to me
it is the fact i'm a living miracle
i'm living proof that the promise of
allah is
true and that's what does that mean
the promise said the promise is dominion
the promise is safety the promise is
refuge
is it not of course it is where is it
for the muslims
very few of them have this and if those
and those who say they have it
it's mostly because they're wealthy and
where do well their wealth come from
mostly because they've stolen it
mostly you see so
um what am i trying to say here well
we've got a covenant
and we've got a promise and we've got
what is it what's this whole thing about
jerusalem and palestine
it's about the promised land is it not
of course it is
so there's the covenant there's the
promise those two words are very very
important
and muslims have lost the promised land
because they didn't keep the covenant
they didn't keep
their half of the agreement that's the
same thing
happened to the jews no same thing
same things happened to the christians
they haven't kept their covenant either
and they've lost dominion in their own
land and have been enrolled by these
cattle barons
and they don't realize it okay so
what does that mean that means that i'll
i'll try to shorten this because i don't
want to prolong this this session it may
be too long
uh for some of your listeners um
the promised land is an example it's
symbolic
okay it was promised to ibrahim and his
seed
and when ibrahim said and to my seed
and allah said to your obedient seed
i'll make it short
okay to to those who keep the covenant
they will maintain dominion those who
don't keep the covenant
no i'm not going to protect them i'm not
going to
you know it it goes back to the to the
curse on cain
because they'll become just they'll
become just as cursed
as kabil was to become one of the
selfish ones
because when you become a selfish one
you bring that curse on you
that's end of discussion so
this promised land is symbolic yeah from
the
denial to the euphrates i understand all
that
but that was for whom that was for the
descendants of abraham
okay and who's the descendants of
abraham the jews
and the ishmaelites
that's who it's for it didn't mean
it didn't give the arabs the right to
cross the euphrates and take over
iran no that's imperialism
that promise doesn't include the
promised land
so the promised land is symbolic
jerusalem is symbolic the ark of the
covenant
is symbolic what is the ark of the
covenant it's the heart
it's the heart so we would here we're
getting back to this narrative thing
heart to heart heart to heart truth
heart to heart this is the sufi goal
and what is the promised land
refuge dominion provision
protection okay
okay that's the promised land and who's
the promised land
well we're all made of mud aren't we
we're made of the land so
we become the promised land when we
obey allah
that's real simple and it doesn't matter
where you are in the earth
if you're obeying allah and you're on
true guidance you will find this refuge
allah will give it to you you will find
your own promised land
whether it is in your marriage bed in
your own little house
or no matter where it is whatever
village you've got up there in a
mountain someplace
i don't care where you are you will have
the promised land right there
and even if it brings you to your death
you will die
happy and you will die
with the uh the covenant from your lips
before before we go on i just wanted to
ask a side question it's not really
relevant
but how many wives have you had and how
many kids do you have
oh dear i guess somebody wants to know
okay
i've been married too many times uh
that's part of my
my uh i guess you could say maybe regret
but
it's also part of a search you see that
men make women make we're looking for
that right covenant
with the right mate and we have because
we're living in a society
that doesn't provide the proper
education in this realm
including islam they're terrible with
the
respect to educating people about
marriage and
the psychology of what needs to be
understood between men and women
uh many mistakes are made and because of
the childrenism the male
is trovenism particular that that that
occurs in islam
that prevents a decent marriage from
taking place so the promised lands
in in marriage is not always uh
accessible
um so i've had uh the
uh i think five wives
and uh uh a number of concubines along
the way
with sort of the you know covenant wives
if you will
um uh that weren't married legally
but five wives who were married legally
and um
i have 10 children that i know about
that i acknowledge now if i have any
other children it could be that
some of these women that i've had
liaisons with in the past
didn't tell me and i don't know they
exist
allah knows so one of the reasons i have
written
a book called the talk of marriage and
i've just finished writing
another book called the sexology for the
wise
is because i have made
numerous errors and we learn
and everyone knows especially mature men
we know that we learn from our mistakes
so uh i've made many mistakes and i
tried to rectify them and i've written
these books to try and prevent
others from making the same mistakes
that that i've
i've made you see so um
having said that i hope that answers
your question no need to get
into all the personal ramifications
although some of those stories are very
interesting
and all of them hold lessons okay
at least they'd hope held lessons for me
and uh probably would be of
use on a further date if we discuss
uh marriage and sexual relationships and
all this yeah
so i think the next episode should be
more on
covered vaccines we can talk about that
another episode could be on
sexual dynamics and all that yes but
before we wrap
this current one i wanted to add some
questions yeah
so there was definitely a lot said today
a lot to digest
man um jessica right here for that
but one question that i want to ask you
and i'm sure a lot of people
have this question how does one go about
living off grid like what are the steps
what needs to be done how can it be
uh sustained for a lifetime
yo listen i've been i've been fasting
all day i'm going to go refund my water
bottle and come back
and i want you guys to just wait till i
come back because i don't want to miss
anything
let's just save that for the next
session okay i'll i'll give you
i'll give you one word uh
work okay it's not an idea
it's got to be work it's hard work
sweat hard work long hours in the field
it's not an easy thing to do and most
muslims
do not have what it takes to do it i'm
going to tell you that right now
they're too abstract they're too busy
praying
they're too busy reciting they wouldn't
do it
they wouldn't do the work they would
they'd do it for a week or so and then
give up
i'll tell you that right now it requires
work hard work
all right okay so we probably stopped
there brother for your sake and
for everyone else's sake and we'll try
and do this again another time inshallah
inshallah all right you've uh you've wet
our appetite
definitely it's gonna be a multiple part
series yup
but rami any thoughts
um i'm completely speechless i do have
questions as well but as the
brother said enough is enough
masha'allah when the teacher says that
we're actually taught you know
atticus the etiquette of the student is
not to overwhelm the teacher or not to
ask him any questions
bless you your family grant you all the
highest levels of jannah may allah
allow the future episodes to come to
fruition and allow us to learn from you
from your experiences and um
everyone look up the books he was
talking about which book would you
recommend
if you could recommend one or two well i
would definitely
recommend trinity and the gospel of
barnabas which
has the title the forgotten saints i
don't think you get the hard copies
anymore they're probably all sold out
but you can you can certainly download
the pdfs
okay perfect i'm gonna link everything
in the description inshallah
yeah wrong anything else that's it
okay i wanted to slide something in real
quick
the main takeaway brothers and sisters
is living in accordance
with the guidance of allah
and this is something that i want to hit
home because
everything that dr omar said was
speaking on is true
how did we even find dr omar zaid it was
through listening to the guidance that
allah gave us
we had a sister her name was milan she
came on for an episode
to speak on you know pollutiony speak on
you know the system
uh the sex industry how it's corrupting
women how they're losing modesty and all
that
and she mentioned in a passing remark
that her father
uh is a freemason right still part of
the occult
and how she's been having these
conversations with them trying to
you know bring him bringing islam to him
and somebody commented that if you guys
want
the man to uh you know guide
you know her too that can maybe you know
help out or make a video it would be
doctor omar zade
when i heard about it i saw that comment
i was like i haven't really heard of
that name
and looked you up sent you an email
and that's how we are here today just
through the guidance of allah
that's how it is that's exactly how it
is
and every good doctor knows he doesn't
have to advertise
because it's word of mouth that brings
the patients they will just come
and that's how it was when i was in
practice alhamdulillah
i was booked three months in advance
i mean it was very difficult to get in
to see me in those years and
i was you know still following the
nerves so
that's saying something you know because
that's the truth that you've just
mentioned there the the truth of what a
man does or what a
woman does precedes them their
reputation
precedes them and this opens doors or it
closes them
okay in certain cases in my case there's
certainly closed doors
so thank you very much brother yes marco
luffy
so guys if you made it this far please i
need all of you guys all of our viewers
to make some extra dua
whenever you're in sujood make some dua
for our brother dr omar zaid that he
finishes
every single goal in sha allah that he
has
in plan for the remainder of his time
in the dunya and that being said i have
nothing else to say
um rami ended up bro all right
uh brother or mormon doctor more male 1
to all the viewers if you like what you
see like comment subscribe share the
video especially this episode with dr
omar and loveless messi also check out
our patreon the lowest tier being five
dollars
if you want to support us further with
that being s
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively more than you're influencing
them positively
i think you need new friends
[Music]
[Music]
um